le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
prendre des vacances lorsqu'on a un
faible revenu ou une situation familiale
compliquée ne pas toujours possible
c'est pourquoi la caf et le département
ont mis en place le dispositif vacances
loisirs en collaboration avec le village
corail
il permet aux familles traversant des
difficultés sociales ou économiques de
prendre du repos auprès de leurs proches
rencontre avec emilienne et ses deux
enfants qui profitent pour la première
fois de ce dispositif
[Musique]
pour goûter le soleil pour aller c'est
une belle journée pour pique et
profiter des vacances au village corail
de l'ermitage
émilienne et ses enfants ont déjà leur
programme cet après midi ses piscines la
petite famille va passer une semaine
dans ce village vacances une première
pour emilienne qui découvrent la
structure se fait jour là c'est
justement dans le dispositif de
relations sociales maintien dans le
groupe pour venir des profiter des
vacances à la plage avec que mes enfants
ils adorent la piscine isère dans l'eau
il adore la plage va dans les vapes
france bon et pour cette dionysienne
saint gilles est l'endroit idéal pour ce
moment d'évasion à quelques kilomètres
de son domicile
les lieux je trouve ses marques à offrir
ce cadre de vie aux familles plus
modestes c'est la vocation de
l'établissement depuis sa création
ancien vvf le village corail est une
propriété du département depuis 2014 et
se consacre au tourisme social
l'objectif du tourisme social c'est
vraiment d'accueillir des personnes qui
sont les plus démunis qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens pour pouvoir partir
en vacances des moyens pour prévenir se
loger ni même se restaurer dans un
restaurant etc
donc c'est vraiment très intéressant
c'est on est vraiment unique sur la
réunion en partenariat donc avec la caf
la caisse d'allocations familiales
nous avons deux conventions qui existe
une qu'on appelle l'aide aux temps
libres et la seconde qu'on appelle
l'aide au fonctionnement vacances
loisirs
émilienne bénéficient de ce deuxième
dispositif suite à une séparation
douloureuse c'est son assistante sociale
à la caf qui lui a proposé ce séjour
objectif s'offrir une bouffée d'oxygène
avec ses enfants loin des problèmes
quotidiens
c'est l'occasion ajustement de partager
des moments de garder en mémoire des
moments ensemble parce que tous les
jours c'est pas facile tous les jours
d'être maman
être ici ça nous permet de se lâcher se
faisait et c'était un maître un petit
moment ensemble se donner la main plus
souvent se faire des câlins souvent ce
dispositif s'adresse aux familles
monoparentales ou non et aux familles
avec enfants handicapés il a été créé en
2011 par la caf et les départements en
fait c'est un dispositif qui est
totalement innovant l'hébergement et la
demi pension est entièrement payée par
la caf et on va mettre en place des
organisations avec tous les travailleurs
sociaux du département qui suivent leur
groupe de familles des ateliers très
diversifié bon le ciel que leurs prêts
avant je la vois pas aujourd'hui les
travailleurs sociaux ont préparé un
atelier musical un peu particulier
ce sont les familles qui décident du
thème et des paroles de cette chanson
improvisée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dispositif a fait ses preuves puisque
depuis 2011 qu'il fonctionne eh bien
nous nous rendrons compte chaque année
qu'il connaît de plus en plus de succès
et cela veut dire tout simplement qu'il
répond à une vraie attente des familles
et aujourd'hui nous sommes heureux de
dire que les familles en difficulté à la
rhino peuvent à travers village corail
ben bénéficier de vacances ce qui leur
permet bien sûr de se retrouver de
partager des moments ensemble de se
ressourcer et parfois même de connaître
un nouveau départ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
unique en france le dispositif vacances
loisirs a été créé en 2011
il permet d'offrir des vacances aux
familles les plus défavorisées
pour bénéficier du dispositif vacances
loisirs il faut être une famille
monoparentale bénéficiaires du rsa avoir
des faibles revenus des enfants porteurs
de handicap ou encore faire partie du
dispositif de parentalité classe
passerelle pour plus de renseignements
vous pouvez vous rapprocher de votre caf
au 0 810 25 97 40 ou du village corail
au 02 62 24 29 39 lien social accompagne
les réunionnais pour la mobilité
alors moi c'est que sauf à l'oeuvre
autant la 26 ans une sorte de saint
denis est actuellement maintenant
contrat pro en tant qu'assistant chef
chantier chez volet c'est juste la
fujistu des camions jusqu'idi rotation
de demande pas de danger est
essentiellement à gérer les dépenses
depuis étant enfant et j'ai toujours
voulu venir travailler en métropole
parce qu'elle va pas découvrir la
métropole déjà et plus beaux voyages et
déjà pour la diversité et puis
aujourd'hui actuellement laissé une
centrale nucléaire que jamais n'aura la
réunion mais en fait le travail d'une
centrale nucléaire c'est complet du
marché
c'est à des chantiers à plusieurs
milliards d'euros donc à la réunion ont
fait à part la route du littoral
on n'aura jamais ça des gens ont pu
faire ma formation qu'il voulait en fait
ce qu'on a toujours voulu être chef de
chantier
aujourd'hui menton accomplir mon rêve
est d'aller plus justement
en fait je voulais faire ma propre
expérience soir même et arrêtez
d'écouter les ondes
[Musique]
on